human beings are hungry for a kind of
ultimate understanding some kind of
cosmic communion some kind of treasure
at the end of the rainbow a pot of gold
right we all dive through the
looking-glass we all tumble down the
rabbit hole with this idea that there
will be some final answer some ultimate
meaning some noetic quality that is
rendered more real than everyday literal
reality right and you know Carl Sagan
the astronomer he used to say that
understanding is a kind of ecstasy we
are cognitive ecstasy addicts we are
living for these peak experiences these
exhilarating neuro storms of intense
intellectual pleasure but these moments
they tend to be fleeting part of the
human condition and then we fall back
into the shadow right for a moment the
curtain parts and what had never been
seen is devoured by the eyes it's
distinct abrupt framed it is already a
memory right we immediately memorialize
these fleeting glimpses of the eternal
of the everything and fall back into
ourselves frail and finite and flawed
and what do we do I believe the immortal
words of Houston Smith but it might be
somebody else who said how might we turn
our passing illuminations into abiding
light how might we render ourselves holy
we have this aspiration to engender
godhood to engender divinity to become
infinite you know and there are moments
right to the tune of the perfect song
when the right instruments harmonized
together the right chorus resonates with
your heart and with your soul you get
lost in the music you get lost in the
moment and everything becomes one and
these peak experiences these mystical
encounters with the numinous what rank
called the mysterium tremendum a fussing
awesome
they vindicate our faith they make us
think yes yes yes there is something
more and sometimes in the iris of the
lovers eye and some
times when exchanging lip-to-lip
communication with a lover you think oh
my god I could just die in your arms
Jamie wheel calls this the bliss [ __ ]
crucifixion to die into the moment to
say yes and be reborn right Joseph
Campbell the mythologist calls this the
apotheosis right after the supreme war
deal you overcome you are renewed you
are reborn and you realize that you are
a god but I could be wrong it could all
be biochemistry it could all be the
secretions and communication and
electrical signals between neurons a
rendering a matrix of mind and meaning
that at the end of the day means nothing
because we die we end up in the ground
we rot and disappear forever what the
[ __ ] that duality gods and worms what do
we do what do we do what can we do how
do we have this dance if we know that
it's not forever Miguel de Unamuno said
eternity eternity that is the supreme
desire nothing is real that is not
eternal I don't have an ultimate answer
I take the plunge constantly I meet a
girl I extend my hand to hers I try to
play the right song I say render a holy
moment with me have this dance right
let's be as gods outside of time let's
commingle with enough with one another
in a space that is timeless that is
beyond self that is beyond you or me
that becomes just us let's render a holy
moment let's have the eternal dance and
then love falters and then the breakup
happens and then entropy rears its ugly
head and [ __ ] what do we do we get back
up and try again
so far that's that's what I say we get
back up we try again
you